less than ten ninety two players average
rating 1783 time handicapped 30 minutes
crazy chest one minute chest experience
level 30 here we go it started right on
time yes did I call that one don't drop
your queen don't drop your queen watch
Bishop g4 Bishop g4 no did I call that
or what
get out of there Bishop man I fall for
that enough I knew that was coming I
knew it was coming okay dark square
issues I can't allow a night to get here
cannot allow that to happen
oooh my bishop was close to being
trapped maybe can I get this pawn no not
really
oh yes I could knight c6 I would have
had to go away I think it's castle push
this night away maybe stay on this
diagonal jump my knight in to f5 or no
maybe not oh yeah maybe I should
how do I capture let's go like this
my knight was hanging on g3 that's why I
was fearful stuff but for luck better
words oh this is scary actually
h5 pawn push Knight g5 this Bishop is a
pain I want to get rid of him oh boy
Knights gonna jump in come over here
should I be afraid I want to get rid of
that Knight pawn push I'm actually ok
with that
my knight is around here I could bump up
here keep pushing push again even if I'm
dropping upon get out of there
I just want my bishop to be able to make
use of that square oh the Kings in check
I'm not gonna give a check I'm gonna hit
play here I think the King might have
been expecting that a little check let's
try it now let's try it again
zigzag my way up here and then give a
check or something
they're down on time let's just do this
anything really anything at all time
burn is what I need back to tournament
somebody has six six four four two two
two okay here we go
you'll have to UM okay here we go what
will you have to do you'll have to
forgive the occasion I don't know how
audible it is but not feeling so well
right now you might hear an occasional
sniffle watch out for the sniffles this
guy might not even uh he's not going to
move double the points there should be a
double in a win back to tournament
that's what happens when you don't move
within 15 seconds you get the flag
thrown on you down you go
six six six a bunch of sixes and a five
out this guy beat me to the punch here
this guy's a beast what is he doing open
Sicilian I usually play the out what do
I usually play my opponent ready to
fishing pull me I usually play I usually
play the closest Ilene let's keep the
Queen's on the board when how often do I
do that whoa whoa wait a second wait a
second watch out for each to there's a
fork but I could back up okay let's go
over here nighty let's go over here
nighty check are they gonna make use of
the G file they'd better not get out of
here night I could take that pun
no no no no no pomp bush is gonna be
strong I think get out of there I
stopped the pawn push as well
Bishop plays here I'm not gonna be here
he is gonna be there get off of that
file feel like I'm missing stuff is the
knight trapped
he might be trapped I could give a check
if the knight moves just back up here
all the way here I want to take that
pawn next that Knight is dead I got the
night um I could I could afford that
check I could just back up on the knight
twice Queen trade
what's the clock situation I only have
18 pawn push I should be able to win
this open up the F file got the Queen
give a check
here no matter what I'm on the night as
she'd taken the night pin the night they
can't get out the pin yes they could no
they can't they should have moved the
Knight to f5 time time time time time I
just want what I want that I want the
position to simplify simplify please
simplify I can't move pieces that are
pinned five seconds no I got the Brooke
got the rook gimme gimme gimme gimme
where's the main this is bad what does
that mean there's got to be an easier
way I think this is okay to do it like
this though no that was me this is me
point eight Oh back to tournaments sorry
don't listen to headphones 0.8 seconds
you got to watch out for 0.8 seconds
they'll get you every time
oh man nail biters everywhere this guy
gonna move you might this guy might be
him at the Comcast gambit or whatever
his ISP is mine's a Comcast gambit 50
seconds he's not moving let me preme I
can't even pre move I don't even know
what to pretty month I'll do that in
case there's a pawn push but I want to
do some home cookin and by home cooking
I mean see who is playing this guy is
not playing okay who is playing this guy
let's see what's going on here
is this my nearest competitor now he
moved forget about watching the game
this guy is uh he's moving he's not
moving I'm looking for fishing poles h2
it might happen again believe me
h2o H dude back to the leaderboard here
twenty twenty twenty twelves a bunch of
12s
three 20s and a bunch of 12s let's try
the open Sicilian okay here we go open
Sicilian maybe get at that up back up
pawn push my rook on D this is nothing
really working isn't really working hi
plan
I don't know if I even had a plan f4 f5
I break this structure down my bishop on
b3 is stupid
believe me when I say that he's stupid I
should have thought that was a silly
sequence of moves that I did there okay
reinforced my Center pawn push next get
out of silly pins or potential pins my
rook out are my bishop on b4 remains an
idiot flight square take my bishop he's
not doing anything good he wasn't doing
anything locked out on this squared the
rook is gonna play here hmm what's that
queen doing she's scaring me for one ah
she's scaring me for one what does that
even do what am i doing oh I see it my
rook wants to be a g3 when I won't push
my pawn my knight wants to be somewhere
else first though my Knight is doing
nothing nothing at all right here he
wants to be on d4 I want to reinforce my
dark squares I have a time edge my
knight wants to be on e5 now okay I have
a plan it's back up baby's hit this pawn
I really don't like having to do that
but I'm gonna do it
Queen g3 Queen trade what's my knight
doing what's this rook up to okay get my
knight into here finally is doing
something good is retention smothered
mate take my queen its main take my
queen its mate this is a sneak attack
and a half Florrick's I had Forks I'm
just gonna take this okay pile up on
that Jeep on I should have done that a
lot sooner
okay right here right here don't do that
just yet
right now right here pawn takes time
situation is looking pretty good
actually they're down on time back
determine thirty forty two forty two
thirty thirty okay
refocus here refocus Sicilian Sicilian
open Sicilian okay I'm gonna be able to
gain a temple I'm gonna be able to tag
that Queen with gain of time here that
night b5 stuff might be available
could just back up to b8 I don't think
it's an inconvenience but I still want
to maybe do what well let's do it anyhow
comes with the tempo and kick the night
away with this I'm winning upon they
might be able to get h2 again this is
with check I'm also covering this take
the Queen I could take that clean and
then take the pawn and then just run
away to this square and how do I
complete my development pond push Bishop
here is actually going to be a bit of a
struggle the bishop should play here to
stop making from casting it's not doing
that and pick up another pun and I want
to cast I don't care about this pond I
want to be gasps allow miss I'm on the
bishop and discovered tricks bishop here
next no right here and then here and I
get that light square bishop and I have
it oh man this is tough it's just tough
for my opponent my kid the King has to
come out here they're going to move no
they resigned back to term at forty to
forty to forty forty thirty a lot of
time remaining a lot of time twenty
minutes time okay Sicilian this time
closed and see what okay okay wait this
is this is a good structure now okay my
knight wants to be here now here look
there would be like Queen a5 stuff and
can I get this in okay that's actually
what is it actually
okay wait a second I don't this this is
a very strategic no I don't know if I
really wanted to be strategic I have no
idea what that mode does absolutely no
idea what is my native of doing okay now
it's kind of close over here there light
square Bishop is dead to the game okay
now I want to play in the plan G file
yeah we're going to have that so my
night definitely wants to get out of the
way because my rook wants to be a G my
knight wants to be on f3 this bishop is
still dead to the game so now I'm doing
the doubling phase now they drop the
night I might resign let's drop back I
might want to triple up on the G file so
that's why I didn't go all the way back
double up triple up they're kind of
paralyzed now um I don't know what I
want to do pawn push jump my knight in
there actually okay oh that's a deadly
deadly deadly fork
okay now everything is just crashing
through mate and one two three Bishop
has to block I guess I should just take
in the rook okay get my get my knight
doing something they resigned back to
term in 56 56 54 42 a lot of top guys up
there the chest chief is in town this
guy gave me a beating he's going to get
he's going to do the Smith Morin oh he
did that in the the cyma I'm gonna take
here okay I almost no that was almost a
bad mouse limb Oh pawn push with the
fork I still have I have a nice scent or
two to zero majority in the center take
with the pond I have two what's my other
option what else you gonna take with man
knife or Bishop okay kick this night
away get my cons rolling and I could get
rolling again with tempo but I don't
want to do it just yet because the queen
is going to give a check I want to
interpose with my queen if there's a
check now I'll do this and now let me
hit this pond and then see about I think
I want a sack get rid of that night okay
I want to be able to take this
immediately it's a little scary that
tricky night I get out of there pawn
push that Knight isn't going anywhere
why'd I allow that night to get there
wow he's got a go you have to go
definitely I cannot deal with you he's
not going so easily though he's not
going or is he okay now we're having
this aren't we we're having this this
pawn has passed I'm on this pun okay
with check let me get back over here and
push my pawn I actually have a lead with
the time here I have a lead with time
okay I don't know how good this is but
I'm going to
and throwing some tricky checks maybe
even look for mate is their made around
the corner sometime burners might be
right around the corner I want to keep
some material on the board time burners
time burners is what I need another time
burner just for fun time burner they're
always just for fun another one another
one
okay they're doing something sneaky back
determine third down on time seventy two
seventy two seventy sixty two sixteen
minutes remaining
okay sixteen yeah sixteen minutes
remaining French okay that is strictly
preventative I'm not sure what they're
trying to prevent against okay this is
like creepy-crawler type of formation
it's not a real thing I don't think okay
I'm trying to do some weakness with h5
mine I could jump into e4 and observe f6
I want to trade our scribe bishops and
throw a knight here it's going to turn
out pretty good and you grab that pun
okay here we go f6 this is what I was
talking about okay okay let me give a
check and then take this night so I
don't have to defend this dark square
weaknesses Newcastle and then push this
pawn this probably could be taken let's
do this f4 this night is not going to go
anywhere fast now I don't want to do f4
if I want to get to g5 a bishop is close
to trapped actually it is trapped I
can't go anywhere now stuck I might go
there do I even take it if it goes there
it might not even need to take a queen
f4 okay I'm on the Queen no need to take
the bishop just yet Queen is running
short on squares rook right here now the
knight is covering that back rank issues
let me just pick up the bishop first
defend this pawn could jump my other
night in there I probably should have
done that a bit sooner that night out of
there jump in here with tempo and then
do what I actually have a time edge I
might want to just push this problem on
this guy as well Queen here I take here
with a fork just trade Queen's a time
edge time edge and I should be able to
pre move everything
from here rook here no matter what no
time anything time burners more time
burners back to tournament ninety ninety
eighty eight eighty less than fourteen
are less than fifteen minutes remaining
Wow okay arc this is going to be close
there's a lot of heavy hitters up there
I have to keep winning I definitely have
to keep winning here let's see if that
happens we're going to see about that
okay stop might be five stuff get in d5
and then see how white reacts to that
okay there's not upon an e so I could
rely upon f6 a bit easier I could
develop with tempo okay the king went
there voluntarily so I could meet f5
with this in fact I want to be in that
type of position that this pawn is
pinned if the pawn moves the Queen's are
in tension with one another what piece
is most aggressive I'm not sure okay
pawn push is that still going to happen
i want to get my okay i was i was going
to do this anyhow now comes with tempo I
think I'm better off oh they missed that
at the Queen they might resign I'm up a
full Queen I'm up a full clean I was
gonna I just wanted to go to g7 that was
my main idea they resigned back to term
at 1:10 this guy is still matching me
110 110 100 we might get paired up see
about that 13 minutes remaining 13
minutes remaining I don't want to go for
close to Sun let's try open Sicilian
with Bishop d3 f4 e 5 ideas ok my queen
oh no no no no no Oh dad Mouse lip I
need time burners now ah man
man I can't deal with the Queen trade
either let's try this ah man okay oh I
thought this was a for take a piece on
its home Square and land a fork but wait
watch out for Age 2 if I fell for that
oh I would have screamed I would have
screamed too believe me now I have it
Wow lucky lucky lucky outs still on the
Queen still on the Queen she's gone ok
clear this diagonal for the bishop
check-check here ooh this nights going
to be dead mate coming up very soon
does this mate bishop has to block
that's got to be made yeah it's back to
tournament 130 110 I have a lead 130 110
107 106 still a very tight pack
Roy Roy rabbit is here okay let's not
drop pieces within three moves let's not
drop upon either okay I'm building a
center I want to reinforce my center
something it's going to come under fire
as otherwise I have a space advantage
space advantage Knight jumps in here
then there's a structural change all
right let's take here clean up Bishop
here if Knight they're looking at age
seven or is that what they're going to
go for that Queen off of her central
post I want a target c2 we trade see to
long term is where I want to be at c2
Knight B five maybe four stuff let's do
this that Knights not really bothering
me now I can jump in here actually
Knight here is probably good I missed
that okay I get this pawn and then this
Bishop get that dark square Bishop pick
up the bishop pair that's a passed pawn
and play Bishop here if Knight there
it's an I could take actually Knight
takes there okay wait a second my bishop
wants to play here challenge the knight
protect my pawn indirectly he has passed
but I don't think that that works
actually the nice to go back I should
probably just push my poem I'm not going
to though let's see what I want to get
my King in a better position no Knight
is close to being trapped let's play
this was that night doing is he up to
okay let's support him with my pawn my
bishop isn't the greatest let's do this
no I would drop that King over to defend
I was going to do this to stop Knight f4
and then go to g7 but now it's a change
of plans actually I don't have any time
it doesn't matter any no time no time
150 130 130
remaining um alright here we go
efore efore d4 maybe I should try some
warm it's okay this Knight is getting
kicked away and now okay now there's now
I'm letting material piece has to
interpose on e7 I just take it doesn't
matter which one plays there okay help
out with my development my Bishop is out
I'm castled I want to get my rook here
here's my next target pile up on that
pond
okay he's free egg takes rotates drop my
bishop back no rook here drop my rook
back just take that first and then the
bishop I'll have two bishops here and
the time ten second no back rank avoid
the back rank tricks right here open up
the a file to get active this covered oh
they didn't take that Oh what kind of oh
I had me I'd have made again back to
tournament 170 almost missed that that
would have been bad I'm glad I saw out
the second time around one seventy one
fifty one forty seven nine minutes
remaining
okay c5 usually I would take right away
okay but I didn't want to do that
because I want to keep things more
dynamic in these Awards owns to some
crazier stuff so I have a good Center I
think if anything b4 should have been
tried to hang on to that pun and I could
jump into maybe I should have done that
sooner meat night here since I have a
space advantage I want to avoid the
exchanges jump into this square should
have done it sooner
um I want to arrange okay my light
square weaknesses get rid of the light
square bishop and jump in here somehow
on that Queen get rid of the light
square bishop s-- mine I could go in
here any day maybe I should take this
night out get rid of him and then jump
my knight into this square on d3 and now
the Brooks can't contest the C file
since I control this square in fact I'm
ready to play here to get the rook
I don't want to do that I want to
eliminate the bishop and then get out
and get in these light squares so I can
women tear with that but I don't want to
do that instead I want to drop this pun
but it's actually to make Bishop takes
Queen takes is that going to be played
Bishop takes Queen takes Knight g4 elite
to me very soon and well throw a peg on
the second now my opponent is ending up
in a giant now right here if Knight B I
play b6 okay let me make sure that guy
is dead and now let me do this I'm on
EFT to the rook isn't there to defend if
the knight moves that I'm hitting that
for a third time now I'm on this Bishop
three times and it really can't be
defended night here okay I'm actually
just getting that now actually if the
rook takes I take on f2 first okay
material no back rank issues I'm on this
again and now I could just play on the
other side of the board then they didn't
mean to do that
the down on time back to turn was going
to lead to mate 191 71-67 seven minutes
remaining seven minutes remaining
okay I need to keep going here stay
focused here
f4 Knight f3 there might have been
Bishop takes Knight Queen h4 stuff that
not going to jump out here I mean ah
yeah this could be annoying actually
the knight is going to play Queen trade
the Queen trade but my king up if Knight
takes this is fine I want to trade a
little bit more my king is in a good
spot he's not vulnerable he's exactly
where he wants to be in game position
the rip there might be a fork if the rip
plays here there's a fork on f6 there's
the fork and now just play up here
expand in the center
not so fast let me just double on the G
file and kick this night away soon I get
I might want to stop Knight c4 after
this he could have made use of that but
not now so get out of the same file I
want to transfer my attention to what
the F file now target that night and
then get to the sixth ring f6 is where I
want to be 33 seconds remaining less
than a minute less than a half a minute
from my opponent grab this pond actually
I'm not even threatening to do that I'm
not sure what this even accomplishes let
me open up another file I want to work
over on the queenside
let's take care do something else I want
to keep these ponds here this night
doesn't have a good home I want to make
sure he doesn't have a good support
point ten seconds for my opponent
okay past pond looking for a fork next
now he has a support point I'm just
going to take them if he goes there
that's not going to be me look check I
just back up night check I just take I
just want to get the rooks off there's
no time either just grab this pond next
no matter what and then over here and
then here no matter what here okay back
to tournament 210 that guy seemed like
you slipped back to ten 187 I have a
little bit of a cushion 210 102 10 187
d5 clamp to get into that III square
maybe let's take that and then defend it
okay Queens coming off I guess they are
give a check and then give a check with
my night pawn push pin that night and
then do this type of stuff okay I am on
this pond er I get this or something
Forks tricky night okay save my night
that's actually just a clean rook that's
he's not going to be captured I'm
dropping this pawn I don't think it
should be it's not too big of an issue
is it just get castle I want to break it
this pawn so my dark Stroh Bishop comes
to life right now my dark square Bishop
wants to play he's gonna be playing soon
he's not going to be playing now oh that
was a bad choice how'd I do that he'd
come out in this direction though 30
seconds remaining
moppet rook it's okay to be down upon
I just want to trade and we are
officially trading Bishop checks rook
activity if this Knight
oh my goodness I just almost drop my
bish up there okay now it's clean much
cleaner I will go for this
it cannot disrupt those over there and
now it's just a matter of getting the
King in a good position King gets to go
back actually my bishop could just come
over here pac-man mode grab these pawns
this one first and then g3 and then h4
back to terment they resigned to 32 to
32 or to 199 Godfather I played this guy
not too long ago in a tournament oh man
dream is this guy gonna move it might be
an easy win they resigned a quick
resigner
Oh 250 ouch okay Kent Kent twenty
thousand three minutes this is probably
the last game I could get in and I have
a pretty good lead actually in this
tournament this is not always the case
if you are watching for the first time
do not be misled okay this should be
seven get in d5 actually let me back up
it stops Knight d5 stuff I still might
want to try that no it's not leading
10th they die by rook on hne more no I
don't know I want to maybe take with my
pawn instead I'm on the bishop okay
where's that Bishop when I go Bishop
takes pawn is available it's still
available pawn push these off that guy
out of there okay this is working I'm on
the Queen I'm still on the bishop here
that was miss played okay just taking
something out Queen to f4 my bishop is
hitting at that point my bishop is still
guarding here just drop my Queen back
right here bishop here and then Bishop
to f5 I want to okay I'm on that
they probably are going to resign I
guess they missed that one I'm up a full
ruck just trade leads to mate sooner you
have to give up the Queen rook takes
rook takes rook King H to Queen f-4g
three rook g1 okay this is going to be
made on g1 don't be a there we go there
we go 272 21 27 oh I have a three game
lead three game lead but this guy is
going to try and put a dent a dent in
the streak or is it even going to end
there's only one minute 16 there's only
one 16 remaining my opponent wants a
draw I'm going to try to win this one
it's probably not going to finish is it
backup capture towards the center let's
have a good reason that - and we have a
good reason not to Bishop f3 my Knights
can be challenges keep my knight around
make the pawn brakes more difficult to
get in Queen e2 still can't get this in
hop the bishop get developed it can't
get developed now I'm just going to take
that tricky night and then post up my
knight on e5 my other thought was just
offer Queen exchange Queen e5 of course
and then break down just maintain this
structure right here that way the bishop
isn't going to bother me Queen III King
f2 and I can focus on h7 let's get that
Queen out of there first 26 seconds
remaining
it's not going to happen is it okay
Queen h2 maybe I'm on this square
actually okay - runaway pawn push is
actually available I could take my queen
is defended
I guess they missed that I almost missed
it as well Knight f4 six seconds
remaining unless there's a one move mate
this game's not going to finish I'm
guarding all my base points by playing -
f - B - and G to guard my knight get my
king up and that is going to be it did
not finish first place confetti land
alright we close out all right
good games ah - 70 - 45 - 42 38 to 20
okay good games oh all righty